oh the arrow I gotta go the arrow
started it all it's a flash because he's
so fast oh that's a weird reason well
see this is a bear these are my friends
um
um I'm keeping I'm keeping Superman and
Lois that's what I'm that's who I'm
keeping oh that's Tom uh maybe the Flash
The Flash Supergirl The Flash come on
the flash all the way Supergirl geez
it's between flash or Supergirl I'll go
Supergirl Supergirl again I'm a girl's
girl we're here for the girls the flash
flash
Supergirl which one had more black
people in it
um the arrow because I remember there
was a black man in the arrow uh
Supergirl the flash people really like
the arrowverse let's go Arrow